wasn't functioning properly
it's good now
uh sometimes Xbox is like
stuff uh to prevent like people piercing
and stuff like activating yeah randomly
for some reason
yeah but it's good now oh pick up the
mess
I got that mask
all right I see the berries and the
stuff
powder
oh put a shield on you
where's my sword
grab that one there
I want that that's the difference
this
oh
I can Mark stuff
I guess over here you snitch
for everything
what to be honest I don't know what it
is
yeah because you're a Sony fan you like
that snitching's life oh my God it's a
battle royale we need to be able to
communicate without talking
foreign
he said he's running late he's got stuff
going on
let me see if he updated
pick up items on the left side of the
menu yeah pick up items
as friends so weak
what the hell is this turn around okay
cut that out
request
oh
oh they go King David he's in the basic
tutorial three minutes I've sent him a
friend request and game
do you still remember how to fight
hell yeah I'm about to fight on God
but watch your monkey to the movies I
was on the IOP account and I
accidentally clicked one of the random
uh videos
yeah
oh
okay you need to be in this stream live
Supremacy I apologize for that live
stream I had to debt it unless you guys
didn't want to hear king of kog in the
game volume for the whole thing see what
happens is Xbox has like this this
feature that prevents you it's kind of
like PlayStation PlayStation ads but you
can manually turn it on and off but you
can't do that on Xbox uh so it seems
like this is snitching it seems like it
just randomly turns on and I had to
reset my Xbox
one of these dudes the ability to know
what we can and can't do about it
is nah
[Laughter]
oh my God
now people are gonna take that I don't
care I don't care what they do I don't
care
I got some more people to uh do that
thing okay
oh okay yeah okay what's going might get
one or two more two coming in hot so I
was gonna give you a heads up on that I
got more people doing the pre-recorded
ones oh cool cool cool
ah
I love it what's up live Supremacy you
said what stream Jacob JW may or may not
you know it's running a little late you
know what I'm saying oh he says Sega is
apparently acquiring an Angry Birds yeah
I saw that yesterday yeah I was playing
Pokemon I saw that yeah it's the choir
is season people are prettier in
themselves up to get snatched up
ain't that right dude and I saw people
in the chat uh you know you you uh just
just ignore that Dead Island too that
was on my dashboard I saw people in the
chat
you funny
but uh the Lords will happen
across the water
all right
ah
yeah we definitely doing bot mode with
y'all
gotta get yourself
oh cookies all right attic let me know
if you got that invite
us us
wait wait a second okay there we go
why are you helping me wasn't it for you
[Music]
let's just say I like the way your
cheeks move
whoa
they got some B randomly helping them
you know what's up
no no this dude talking to me all right
they gave me a chick about to pull oh
yeah they gave you um
oh so it won't allow you to pick up
trash I like that yeah they got it kind
of like that custom trade yeah you
picking up trash for no reason all right
aim to grappling hook
right
ah yeah
kid is doing the training y'all
[Music]
attic is picking is a character you want
this fist on yourself trust me you
should start a little but like slobo
said a little confidence
in the blade is my paintbrush
the doctor
yeah the squad is they are in training
and the dojo right now because they're
both of them well actually I think attic
I played the Rocco with him he did
actually like it yeah he actually did
like this would be in The Rocker for
like two weeks straight yeah this will
be King's first time
yeah the rest of Lords are new
um and uh we will uh so all should be
coming you know later on now what we can
do if people have the rock if enough
people have the rocker we can create a
room with a community
and it's a game pass so yeah yeah go get
that so then there's no reason why you
guys don't have it
[Music]
just saying
I want the Japanese games
are you I don't think this is Japanese
yeah
you know every time I talk about games
on Xbox
what's wrong with you you're supposed to
like the Asics and nothing else
they they ignore all the times I I give
PlayStation that smoke but when I give
Xbox that smoke it's an issue
they're all Kings fans
thank you I appreciate that are you sure
you can handle me oh homegirls are you
sure you can handle me oh god
oh that's um oh Justina cool yeah yeah
[Music]
over there
he ever know Sean that's fine
now King might like to do they gotta
Doogie I'm saying he got his little
samurai oh yeah that dude right there
the boy hey he's still he's his super he
turned into some wow okay if I've been
there just you don't cover the Box
uh-huh
Sam but yeah Community I see y'all up in
the head back from deadline Supremacy
between oh you're gonna download right
now all right all right we're
downloading
see last person play every day
okay
if y'all got it let me know cause it
ain't nothing for me to create it seems
like a fairly easy process I thought I
was buns or something man come on man
it's crazy how I know when I play Elder
ring bro that two weeks I wasn't making
shorts because the packs and stuff we
went down to a hundred and uh like 50
some subs a month and one week of
creating shorts for up to 230.
salute
closer and closer to that 15K
yes sir we're like 700 away from it
I sent you an invite in game so if you
look in the upper right hand corner it
should be like all a little the little
main signal
frame signaling upper right hand corner
yeah yeah get over there
and go to yeah go to France
[Music]
up there
you're an encounter it's crazy
don't say nothing that's private message
that's just message what about yeah that
to the right of it there you go that's
last oh lots of privacy oh okay okay
but I I invited you took my own
semi-trackers
[Music]
that's the only thing when the rock is
uh
send me another one
yeah
Alex
I'm almost finished
doing all this extra stuff I see no my
bag is full you may have my power I
don't need no more grappling whatever
that is worth to invite to rule so I I
just sent you an invite to room
there's no way you can accept that
oh Phoenix blast
[Music]
so when you click on my name itself the
web you don't say nothing but try
private message check check profile
invite to them and find memory all right
you will fight me the room and fight you
will fight be the room let's see what
happened right man
see if I won't go up let's just say
right there next to Gia Eagle invite me
tomorrow
oh I'm already an accustomed okay
so I don't want me to do that great
[Music]
but
behold
not enough energy
all right
um
[Music]
all right leave that custom room
all right I'm gonna see it's crazies
uh you are a little bit
it's probably something simple yeah
[Music]
don't make me quickly
yo it is too many fish out here in the
sea stop it
man I just fight man if you don't get
off me
I'm just relaunching it again attic
do I have to finish this tutorial yeah
letting that don't show it out and learn
you're ignorant
to the sleeves
oh I know what it is because I was best
I know what it is I was messing with the
big rule with the community
and they still had that up there close
rule it's been a ruin that's why okay
I think I was in there with you
yeah we was already in the big that was
what I was making for the community to
test it out yeah now I see you're a
party invite I can ignore requests from
this place there we go
characters
was a was a Max look at these
questionable characters
it ain't my fault they women half the
time
the body always
have a certain look to them
it's very appealy
oh don't you do it Coco
yeah Coco don't you do it
[Music]
her full name is Coco Chanel Johnson
my dog like that bro
I don't know why that made me laugh
this is mad Hood
[Music]
IES
yeah but if we do the big Community rule
that everybody could be in the same
world doing a battle round together
tell Saul just to take his time because
yeah
but we do want to be back to home
I see lots of playing first time playing
yeah it's his first time
Galveston what's up
[Music]
yeah let me let me just quick and get
out of this all right cool gotta appear
online
what is going on here I got him at it if
you go
go to friends go to social
yeah you should see I saw him messing
around it had his name and I was able to
add him messing around us Aspergers
because I think I added it
who think you are bruh
and I'll just get up there right yeah I
keep weapons in the back pocket
yeah we gotta wait for him to finish
that and then once he finishes
I think this is his very first time
yeah see I see a basic tutorial
certainly send my friend requests
so once he finishes I'll show him how to
send us the the question
oh now I gotta go also does this does
this stuff that I get carry over
yeah yeah yeah well law school you
seeing um addicts lost green um guys
that I have downloaded on Xbox can't get
it working on a PC telling me I have to
turn off kernel isolation which doesn't
sound like a good idea you don't want
you you want to keep your kernels
never seen the rocket so I'm interested
oh you never see
this thing on Game Pass Lydia
I look dope
oh I know it
I knew it I knew it
this dude sets you up we'll get you up
there so you can work it
acceptable
are you finished with that tutorial sir
nah they got me in there with this some
dude named Henry
what do you have to do it well Henry
over here trying to work me forward oh
man they got you fighting yeah all right
the doctor you installed so I'm
interested if y'all make the room
I mean I could make the room
yeah let me you know what you want me
you want me because how many of y'all
put in there doctor who else is in there
if it's at least three to five four
y'all that ready ready to rock we just
make the room while we waiting for King
King is almost done because this dude
that he was gonna work me but I put the
moves on them
you didn't know I got it like that
she wanna be wifey like that I think
live Supremacy you got it downloaded too
right the Dodge let me know in the chat
who's got it downloaded and if it's
enough of y'all got it download it then
I'll make the room tell you what the
room name is and get this popping
a lot of Supremacy you got it the doctor
you got it anybody else
[Music]
I did all that blindfolded you heard me
or attic I'm gonna show you how to make
it
all right so you see in the top just
press right bumper attic all the way
over to you go to the room we will I
couldn't even imagine what this looks
like not on that series that
if you notice is on Xbox one I got I
could not even imagine it
we going rule both Lord addict you ain't
got to mess with leave everything thank
you for your purchase it is ranked then
press X create room
just press X oh I can't do it
oh all right so let me leave the room
with you all right basically yeah
so I left your rule all right now try it
yeah his name is David the slow
yo yo yo whoever's being slick with
their mouth man throw it in the bushes
yeah Jacob Miller said David the snow
Yeah David you're finished
oh there we go
uh let me just reboot it there we go
that's my guy right there
tell mileage
yeah appreciate it you said first time
actually catching you guys live actually
I think I have some
well my dude got a perm
um
vagabonds
oh I could do the ball headed yeah I'm
I'm cool without other stuff
yeah I'm not doing that whole he calling
you David The Unfinished David
as long as this Galveston can say
whatever you want but whoever else is
better Super Chat
let's see what weapons yeah so this is
where all right so that they gotta tell
them I guess like we got to search for
the room of addict we go see
we'll enter room name yeah so what
what's your name it's called through
room of Lord addict
[Music]
how do you just say this is who you want
because I don't want that other person
okay who's this dude
[Music]
of course I know I could tell you right
now who added oh they go room alert at
it okay cool 260. oh we got 60 people
no that's lit no you can have 50 people
shut up in Xbox
Battle Royale rule
Sam what's up yeah you can wear your
Crocs if you get in this game back for
that let's go
we're just gonna Squad up and run but we
solve is the way to be found and then
look at attic control situation
get in
lowest Supremacy today
what's the real name
okay so it's called the sorry so you
gotta press right
all the way to okay School press right
bumper all the way to room at the top
and then once you type it in then press
the search button again and you're gonna
see the rooms the rooms come up and then
you can pick it I know I know you guys
got game
passion a front download this joint this
is Lobby
all right I'm in the lobby
to get wrong it should say search in the
upper right move the cursor to see a
little little search box that's what you
gotta type in that box oh my Lord at it
you mean Chambers list Justice Chambers
you're at the top of your screen it says
step season seven shop in room
well my joint starts off with Lobby's
Heroes weapons training but Showdown
rank inventory season shot
shot
at the very top nope
wrong with the top
you probably did you finish this
tutorial yeah
okay yes I did
all right so let's do this let's add
all right you see in the upper right
hand corner they got the little um
little means and the emails
yep all right click the little man
inside it should be read and see if you
got a friend in request from me
already yeah yeah
in there getting the mix
it says private message check players
profile check profile add nickname to
invite to a party nope
okay but oh wait we are friends already
so we are friends
I'm gonna invite you to the room let me
see if it works okay did you get that uh
oh the players level is not sufficient
yo so that means I gotta go play around
here let's just go ahead and me you and
him play a couple matches well because
there's people in the in the chat
downloading it so okay okay so what
we're gonna do then is we're gonna go
dead this one and then play a joint we
can't what we doing yeah let's just get
something up today and uh yeah because
there's people in the chat downloading
the game so let's just uh play a game
with just us all right so the doctor
Jacob hold on y'all hold on we just got
to get King up to speed and then we're
going through the chart no they make me
do my own
you gotta get
it get into action
see but I did it already that's what's
so so crazy I remember playing the video
remember when it came up
each day
okay the words they're doing here
please select this Communications
so welcome to Morris Island
with 60 Heroes can play around
we will be to the world
yes they're real every single of them
you can never have too much
yeah yeah yeah I gotta all dude that's
what killing going through oh God do
that look he was licking the blanket
Coco
tutorial
[Music]
but
okay good oh there's a dude here come
here
come here bro
I'll put this on you
so attic what you want to do in the
meantime
I guess um
we're just going as a two
yeah
it's already ready
yeah I think um
Supremacy whatever
he's in a match oh he in a match yeah
let's go
do um
do the pot drink so we can warm up
not a picket yeah
yeah
a lot more easy yeah
we're gonna put Duos put Duos
or wave King
you got trios you got trios
you gotta move into Duos
go back again go back in there and then
see how left trigger left trigger will
put you yeah there you go now confirm
there you go start up
yo stop judging me he said car
characters look expensive don't don't
worry about how I got the clothes I got
she stopped pocket watch this little
more I see what you're doing I I could
have earned that
I might have
seen some stuff on sale
[Music]
I'm supporting the deaths
hmm
all right y'all y'all get some of the
rocket action
[Music]
all right so we'll be starting that
attic we'll put us to the city of tank
put us in the city of tank stop it
well I could put us in the city
all right I ain't gonna pick some quests
um except travel using the grapple hook
I could do that
oh yeah
what else arrive get one Africa better
in the pool Castle now I ain't picking
that all right cool oh this is a new bed
I never said that what's up
oh this is me oh God
I never touched this before I wonder why
I know where to go
oh
we got this the winter child bio oh
this guy is supposed to
be oh diverse is lit yeah you gotta
press that that Grappler I added this
what we gonna do what we gonna do
yeah all right we're gonna see it we're
gonna get in there see that background I
got don't worry about how I got that but
it looked nice right oh a whole boat
yeah oh yeah
all right cool I'm an attic where my man
at again I see you number one all right
read the houses just got to raid the
houses
oh cool
not the item I have marked
oh my control is a little messed up
something happened to my control
I gotta change I don't have my what's
your polish strikes
that's counter oh I got a little trigger
okay
oh I see you number one okay I'm gonna
get over to you
hit the roof I see you at it there you
go there's attic all right let's go lose
some houses
over here
there's Blues over here
okay
all right then I think Press Start is
for your inventory you could choose
which weapon you want to primarily yeah
okay oh let's go over to the belt
got him
she got it got it
you could also grapple onto them
there's two of them
all right
now remember you could hold you could do
rechargeable but you turn that blue
those are kind of unblockables
that's right and don't forget your
abilities you have a y ability
yeah there we go all right let's problem
let's Rob let's see what they got let's
open up there bye
Essence let's go
all right there's a great sword and a
long sword okay
weapon bag is full all right so let me
change this uh cover me one second
because I gotta I want to change out my
armor
our armor is whole again
I have beef I have beef that's you okay
pick up the blue
how do I look at myself
holy to swap
swap on the blues oh depressible to swap
that
right now I'm good
yeah I don't know where you got your
control at it's been a while
so what we gotta do is we're still in
the middle if you press select you'll
see the purple circle in relation we got
to start heading towards that Circle at
like typical Battle Royale
I'm gonna put like a marker
so you can see where we're at let me
know when you're ready and then we'll
start oh traversing over there because
we got to get out of we're in the
outside of the circle
dude got my first win all right let's
get to that rules and just wrap them up
let's take the high ground
give me the dark coins
okay yeah let's get on top oh it's beef
up top there's somebody up top here on
top of the house
yeah I just like are you fighting them I
see them now they're down there
that's jumper
oh didn't come she came up here
come here and bear arms
yo I got beef for the Rooftop
oh it's two people
oh they fight each other
all right beefing though yeah cause I'm
beefing
all right
[Music]
in the world
down here
okay and one second I'm streaming
you gotta jump us
hey remember to hold down the the charge
nice
all right let's rock the bodies
all right we can pick this up we're
gonna use the arbor powder
all right we gotta start brewing because
the corruption is going to spread
let's head towards the Waypoint
this way whenever you ready
all right
bag extension for two thousand I got no
point you ready all right let's go
there's a body here
yeah we got a shot let's drop yeah we
gotta get going all right cool
all right let's get up top
even walking off
yeah we gotta get we got a long way to
go too yeah good call
if you see any like katanas let me know
I like katanas or you see dump trucks or
blue ones let me know
you have blues or you have regular
weapons
oh you got purples
yeah remember to use the armor powder to
repair the um
what you call it
yeah I'm gonna try to get my joints
and repair it oh
you see beef let me know
here you go
oh what's this love
is it purple I need purples
they blue come on Fast boy
the best for them
little joke that shadow corruption
yeah I'm dead
yeah the soul also
beef beef
ready ready
[Music]
I got him
things above
oh we gotta be out we gotta be out of
five together
oh that's something different oh no no
that's something different
okay
check this out this is our marker all
right so we're in this circle we good we
can kind of chill out let's loot yes
Soul sucker sucker
oh you take that weapon bag extension
damn it
it's cool I better look up the top of
this Temple
oh I got no grappling hooks oh no
that's not good
oh there's a gold body right here
durability repair
yeah it's called count this straight boy
call my body
oh beef
beef okay
I don't have any Grappler hooks I'm in
the middle of the beef oh I'll get a
list of
I haven't used to get up here
all right I'm fighting though
[Music]
if you win you can rescue but be careful
books
[Music]
be nice with that weapon
you know
yes hurry up
I'm not supposed to get up here
[Music]
he caught me out of pocket I had no
Grappler hook and nowhere
I didn't find the weapon on the ground
uh let me see anybody got a grappling
hooks up just about it yeah he do
there's a Obama part of it
oh my goodness one day perhaps I will be
more
beef
okay okay
oh okay
you know what yeah
oh it's two
[Music]
that's crazy
go
sh
don't forget to use your abilities
unlike I did
the Republic
[Music]
with that
I'm good
Addy gotta you gotta hold it down for
the team
oh
yeah yeah what the hell did he just turn
into you sure
get out of there oh he turned into a
whole big person
oh
hey yo and he throwing hands at me
all right
oh don't get off me get off me I got a
struggle button
[Music]
I just want to play matches for myself
first to learn the mechanic that's fine
jacket that's fine
yeah I think you are yeah you definitely
required to do the tutorial my
understanding first
[Music]
I guess we'll just start again
yeah you can start that one while we
wait for King
I'm sitting there teach it
yeah oh yeah let me because I could
change my settings too yes I'm with my
control up here it is the All-Seeing Eye
you died Big Fish boy
[Music]
to dagger you got daggers floating in
the background with the oh wait
oh Wing style oh you won't you saved
your voice okay
[Music]
said do you want to skip this part or do
you want to the Glorious yours
[Music]
there we go
let me know now once you finish that oh
what's this
rocking the rocker
I don't like that I'm excited sit there
and put that in your blade point
ah
that's me feel me
let me see
all right cogs and party okay so there's
the same room at the top down next door
says lobbies Heroes weapons chamber
Showdown rank inventory
seasons and and Shop
he could join us though all right so
what we do send them my advice
it's not all my thing
um King I'm gonna send you the invite
right now relax
take the party all right kick I sent you
the invite yes I accept I accept yes
okay so now check yeah
all right yeah
oh you take it you take it um
start up
[Music]
everyone's got it already up
oh I'm an idiot
sorry I always forget the radio upstairs
radio
[Music]
are you ready uh
yeah you just press it okay
[Music]
I'm gonna start off in the Imperial
Village
yeah although I can't select the support
location
[Music]
yeah City attack city attack
all right a challenge day one the ride
again won't rev and the Imperial Vision
that I ain't thinking that imma back out
of these challenges all right cool all
right yo make sure you run around in
these spools man
he's a little uh
Whirlwind kick yeah
you got the right bumper for the car I
mean I got my gotta know what your
counter button is too okay with a blue
flash you to counter that from Flash
[Music]
so we're gonna Loop together
of course
I already got that character of course
I wonder the voluptuous characters whose
character is that the sexually
attractive character this guy is
questionables
a whole lot of choice
make sure you get some weapons bro we
gotta get some weapons
get
to The High Ground
sword though what's going on
I got no y'all this way okay
all right
oh won't you I don't see no weapons
nah you get that gold chest oh
yeah
all right but we need weapons though all
right oh there you go some stuff over
here come over here
oh over here
where's no weapons like this
the top of this house what's up what's
up beef I can't fight y'all gonna have
to work that out I got the weapon
[Music]
you attractive milkshake
if you want to fight or not it don't
matter I'm bringing them to you all
right all right cool I got dump trucks I
got I got basic dump trucks without
anything where's you I see
I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
oh yeah
[Applause]
where you at people where's your basket
where's your coach
I'm scared
none of this stuff is yours why are you
over here
yo we got a little talk about it that's
what we talk about dude we coming in
here
enjoy
let's go this that way so we can get out
the before the purple Disco
you know
because my stuff was stolen from me on
ceremonious Jackson
oh you jacked it yeah I know oh we gotta
get inside here this sore
are you at the house y'all got Robin
I already robbed King enough yeah
he took he took my gold items that I
fought for
fighting bullets
you ran from those same Bots
and I killed two of them
[Music]
yeah I left something I had beef
oh King out here he know how to do the
identifier oh there's a gold package
here yeah I left that for you there's a
gold package weapon baggage there I had
beef yeah
outside he buy you all right he's right
there oh yeah
oh it's two it's two oh they go get this
they go get this super this time yeah
um
triple kill
I now have coffee two dudes down here
over there
a lot
fingers you still fighting far how did
how did he go that far that's all to say
you'd be doing the same stuff
quadruple kill
there you go you better heal up
all this truck [__] kill him
I totally helped you need some armor too
yeah kidney mama he ain't got no armor
Attica armor I ain't got no arm
attic is over here still my armor
obese wow it's here
don't forget your special abilities
like the provides his life or whatever
ah let's stop at it yo protect me while
I get this um oh
it's two on one all right now I got home
thank you
what's up
buddy
[Music]
that's my big bro God
body
powder
all right dude
my weapon
all right cool
I got that
how we doing I don't know how King you
need some armor I need armor anybody
took my armor already if y'all see armor
let me know one of these bodies I got my
armor powder
armor
I got a chest piece yeah I need a chess
piece yeah that's what I need if y'all
see a chess piece let me know
yeah I need a chess piece because y'all
got all y'all got almonds at me
oh let me eat my berries let me press
direction to eat my berries
yeah yeah who put the arm oh thank you
attic put it on the thing I'm coming
hold on you want it there that's what I
got yeah give me a second
let me just get this one out of God real
quick
that's me he said I heard somebody
yeah I'm making it to my my marker
oh there's three people coming
now
I have wow
we gotta move we gotta move the thing is
um it's coming
oh where you at
I'm coming I'm coming go go go go go
there's like five people behind us go go
go go run the king brother kick King is
in the circle kick is in the circle yeah
of course King is away from us when the
beef goes down yeah of course cake is
down uh I'm sorry I'm killing people up
front I've been marked that
[Music]
[Applause]
behind us all right
keep running let's go to the center
let's go let's go meet in that Charlotte
Temple over there
Temple
let's go in there let's recruit and then
I gotta get something upstairs I mean
the giant I'm gonna enjoy it all right
we're in the temple order some green in
here there's items in here
all right
so I hear them man I hear them too
attic always hearing somebody killing
somebody oh God
marker at once
what
oh I heard something something terrible
they should have down here all right
don't get out the circle too deep
I'm gonna put a marker deeper in the
center of the circle so that we we Okay
we okay we're enjoying I'm looking
forward I'm going to what attic I'm
going towards the market so y'all know I
marked it
oh yeah
foreign
[Music]
what color weapons you got kid you got
to change up to them I gotta go uh
purples oh okay cool I got blues if
y'all see purple weapons let me know
because I ain't got none
and let's see that's the joint when I
went up to the castle I went to the
couch okay okay okay
all right I got the purple armor attic
does this show I have armor on my energy
ball oh no no you have none
yeah why did that's [__] me oh cover
these armor powder oh what's up
all right
oh now oh there's a bunch over here we
need you here now
all right
[Music]
purple nunchucks
that means that let's do the swappy swap
purple dump trucks Oh Thank you very
much very much thank you very much oh
let's see where we go with that let's
get the equip on that please yes yes
come
to all vitality
if that purpose get these coins yeah
yeah
the shadow begins all right a shadow
about the club good we're doing good you
know there's only 18 people left
I can't do it too much as always
oh yes another one thank you what you
found what you found
you find a little secrets you finally
you do the little quests you dirty yes
yes
they're about to get these hands
oh all right let's go back to edit
it oh yeah oh they fight too
[Music]
boys
get crazy get crazy let's get crazy
[Music]
okay let's go
I'm invincible
[Music]
let's get it let's get it Invincible
what
anymore
invisible my arm is restored nice all
right let me get these let's Rob them
yeah they're here
I need to heal I need to heal my energy
low
oh that was the perfect sword right
there
[Music]
thank you
all of you
[Music]
everybody else
there slow down
all right
what's this I still hear people yo it's
still beef there's a bouncy right here I
got it
still be
I can't accept any more quests
get them
enough
you can you go get it now
we've been doing this for 300 episodes
she wasn't ready
I said oh yeah
[Music]
who's sneaky
so y'all ready for that that room ready
for that room
[Laughter]
yo tell me why wifey is sick to death oh
my god
oh yeah she was like oh my God it's it's
ravaging me
nobody
to you is me
go to community room or we just doing we
just run it again with the real humans
let's get these guys
who want this The Rocker action we want
to get in this room who's downloading
naraka
who's downloading the Rockers
support the real
I gotta customize my dude because that
bald head life
I got I got no bread
action yes yeah I see I see what just
went down
there's like check your clothes you're
just washed
I said oh you want to get the chasm the
under oh let's see your code let's get
it gold
they got the dragon Shadow bringing they
got the giant yeah
they just did it they just did it they
just it's over
you're illuminated Lotus
yes it's crazy just unlocked by lotus
treasure
oh you are unlocked by signing into the
Spring Festival unlocked by doing
treasure unlocked by Bruce Lee crossover
that's expired
oh look at this dude oh fine yeah
why you think I got caught up in the mix
look at this joint what's that game that
I like
um
uh the some it was this game that was on
360. oh the doctor's ready
doctor's ready
Galveston trying to level up some
more vampire survivors let's play
another one and while we wait for them
hold on hold on I could buy this I could
buy this hold on you don't gotta Isis
man out
what's up
[Music]
let's go
get it anyone in the chat that wants to
play just tell me and I'll send invite
you may have my power
whatever
yes they're real every soul in this
blade
I gotta get gold in order to do this
thank you
[Music]
I just got done with some scoop some
school stuff and okay
and I seen y'all were playing online and
I was like hey
what's the community streams I've been
trying to get them to play this game for
so long they got the deity of Slaughter
oh I got kickers
my God
all the transactions
oh they got the clouds
[Music]
come down they got the X they got the
Xbox
and [__] you got some Game Pass for
exclusive rewards you can add for your
suits too
I'll show anybody do those later this
dude is extra right here
now we got more than three
yeah
make the room name short so that they
don't gotta type as much something
come on the doctors
these would be loud
yeah what is going on
buddy they got the blood red fire sword
for the devil
right they got this death of me weapons
son these are these are weapons that you
find in the in the channel 5 yes
this is the end game weapon
okay
oh
it's like every time you do something
you unlock something we never even done
that you know there's a campaign mode
I was campaign yeah it's cool yeah it's
called Showdown Showdown I think it's
also three player that's the people
the the room is IOP 300.
you can invite us directly to them
[Music]
it says you cannot use a custom
party
party first okay what is the Justice
Chamberlain
level one Justice chamber no need to
apply I don't want applications
oh this is when you gotta join a group
Justice chamber
again then
show downstairs
PC masturbates too let's go
let me see the season pass what the
season pass
and now I don't like
that forcing you to use the girls though
all right I like that I like that outfit
who is it all right so what's your match
with you guys what you're gonna do is
this well when you go to the um
have you played at all it's your first
time really kind of booting up no I know
I've played before Okay cool so what you
do is in the um at the top you saw you
got Lobby Heroes weapons you want to
write bumper all the way over till you
get to room
and then in the room you're going to the
name of you're gonna do a search in the
upper right hand corner and then what
was going to be called ILP 300. I'm
gonna search for that rule well send me
the invite again
George yeah
what's this journey of the Dawn what's
this
day one
I don't know if it works bro
he can't nope what if we go to your name
hold on I think I can do it
[Music]
yeah I'm level three
this is ridiculous
[Music]
yeah and your love was insufficient I
can't even get in ah yeah but you can
hang out with me add me as a friend
[Laughter]
Us Versus Them call ah I'm down
default
[Music]
that's what I'm trying to turn leveling
off
see that's right it might be an option
for that Atticus right
yeah we may look at that option it
should be just like uh
yep everyone should be elated go to the
middle don't don't make us chase you
down go to the middle
you can
or you started this you Beastie yeah go
to South Street whatever it's called
don't make us chase you oh you can put
it on a casual
yeah casual we got survival they got
quick match what's the name of the group
is an iron body
[Laughter]
hahaha
oh God
that's what he is here
in the room already
don't worry about it it's just us gonna
be fighting uh the two people from the
chat that has it
they said they're going to swan in the
middle I hope they swam in the middle
yeah they
they say say less
you guys already start playing yeah
we're gonna fight these I started it
already but I was trying to tell them to
wait so we could figure out the level
addict has zero patience
so we're just hanging out yeah yeah okay
oh they got a naraka mini game
level five is the minimum required so
it's Libra X
RX
oh so you have your level five to jump
in the uh the rooms jump in a room
but then they could but but what Locker
said is what in the room set up we
probably could make the um leveling
requirement
this dude said
he said we will dominate our enemies
after we try to uplift them you know he
is stupid as
I hear feet
oh I hear I see one of them I see one of
them too I'm coming over there
see them boys
yeah somebody bring me back attic knees
chop off his knees and bring them back
to me leave it to King to ask someone
else to do his job
that's right
beef beef
why are you running Phil while you
running I don't run down and we won't
talk it out
yeah they put shields on it every day
I got you I got you give me up give me
up give me up
[Music]
what's good
very cool
yeah no no but that was that was um that
was them that was your man yeah
somebody in the chat was that the
community that I bought yeah yeah
we dumped you you should have been in
that house we told you about that
here
I don't think because they I don't think
they're spawning back
no it says four look it says four laps
so that's one two yeah
told you murder is real yo got back
still on the doctor that's what's up
it's very easy to set up
oh that's right because they could
revive one time that's right that's
right
let you beef it at it no
get your help
separate the two
separation and then you take attic while
he's by himself
I dropped armor powder right there
that armor powder I need armor I need a
chess piece sorry
what's up
I bet you they're trying their hardest
not to let that happen
to the wrong club we had to get up there
armor
all right cool I have marked the record
that's what I think
[Music]
oh
let's go all right we gotta go we gotta
go find him
yeah let's go find the community and
kill him
some pretty cool gear and all that stuff
yo my boy just yelled out I am
undecieged
hey bro keep in mind man when they find
us they go They're gonna hit us hard
right no oh bro what are you being here
money didn't know I could turn into that
big dude
you guys find them you guys still
running around oh I'm not looking at the
stream I probably should look at the
string okay
I see you I see you on top of the roof
oops all right I hear songs I can't I
can't give you the location now yeah
don't do that
oh you you know they stream sniping
yeah
they
were stream snipers hello
are you
there get him get him
I heard the community was here
[Music]
I heard about you then you gotta move
your lips
he was
oh
a lot of Supremacy use the supers
you shot
yeah shout out to the IOP Community the
glory is yours
good good bad Supremacy good batch
I I popped my super and my dude was was
moving around too much so I started it
your dude with my speaker
it killed me
it's a community or Community violence
all right so we ready what level
um lock is we gotta get locked in here
for the um level I'm level three
yeah we got to get them it says host
so you can look yeah check yeah let me
see
so it's gotta be let me go to room
all right let's see
y'all don't know
come here let's see General
Party come here come here
seats receding
I had to walk hide the room from cross
platform players wow
that's what's funny
that is hilarious game so
um
get out of there boy
balance
are you compare that custom stats
well I had to climb a tree to get away
from a dude why bro he's a bad weapons
[Music]
have everyone go in there with daggers
I know that'd be hilarious man right so
they got referee actually what king
what's the weapon you hate the most
your knees seats
well considering yo yo Posse couldn't
take my knees either so I think I'm
pretty safe
yeah I'm talking crap against y'all I
told y'all to isolate him and beat his
knees in
oh they they tried they took me out both
times but good good job guys bye then
if damage is already done like all right
Jacob how do you create yeah the rumors
open to all beaches uh libara all right
so um over to check out the PV sort of
all right how do you join when a group
is created so what you want to do is go
to the room option in the top right
Jacob then see how we got IOP 300.
just got to do a search for that in the
upper right hand corner you should be
able to join the room right to the net
while I'm doing this let me um add y'all
to my friends doctors
in care because there's an in-game
friendless as well
all right Supremacy yeah we wait a
Supremacy we're gonna see what other
people are joining lock are you able to
find iop300
oh nunchucks
oh slow mo give me friend request all
right I see slow I never use nunchucks
before but I'm about to use them now
oh that's right because you're that
opportunity you're level three though
right
yeah
what you and King need to do is probably
play together with the what you call a
mode and get the love get your level up
by just doing like one quick I thought
he was gonna join me
yeah so what you need to do is add each
other on the uh in the friends in the
upper right corner it should be like a
little email icon and then there's like
a little friends icon let's go and then
go on the social yeah you should find
each other and add each other that way
[Applause]
I know that the UI is a little
cumbersome but
they want you to change it out of the
range mode
oh they should change it out of right
mode
yeah you drop that rank down
room settings rank bold
it just says right mode the bloodbath
through the fire
yes it's through the fire
players nine
minutes
Bloodsport
16 players to love that
see but when I play Red Bull that's the
only one that does 60.
weapons Chambers Showdown rank you don't
get over there help boy
[Music]
can the Moby change from rank the wrong
tag ain't showing up I'm not seeing a
room though maybe it's setting all it's
a setting on my end
yeah the level five requirement lydian
is the problem yeah that's what it is
the reason why y'all not seeing the room
setting the room tab yes
so yeah that's a there's a bunch of
stuff I need to unlock yeah and what's
the what's the fast track to level five
just probably I just joined a
matchmaking
play the box right yeah because I think
yeah I'm sorry
did you guys do you guys in level 11 box
I'm like level 15. I love it up in the
Box quick
dude said I'm level 15 and 16.
yeah if I change it off right mode then
it won't be the Battle Royale mode
oh
I was just telling you
yeah that's the only thing
I see slo-mo in there I see the doctor
[Music]
is this like every man for themselves
it seemed like it as opposed to the
teams though
[Music]
I guess just launch it
yeah let's just launch it because they
got to get to five they got to get to
five yeah if y'all get the five
why are we doing this imma start it
slows in the doctors in everyone go to
the middle map
[Music]
thank you
that's addict's trick
[Laughter]
it's working very well
pick them all from a distance knock his
teeth out from yard
don't let him tell you how you fight
go to plunge Castle blunt Castle
let's go
the Cog ain't gonna be there so you got
them now
welcome y'all
[Music]
got a lot of hate in your heart for me
right now
[Laughter]
yeah I guess that's what happens if you
keep losing Bets with them
yeah yeah
he wants a strong wind don't tell him
what to do just
not only do I have have your knees
hey addict we'll play some Tekken after
this
I'm done
yeah I didn't think so I ain't had
nothing up there somebody says I get to
level five man Jacob what did you do to
get to level five fast so I know
tell the chat what you did because we
want to get people up in there
he said there's an icon at the top and
it costs 75.50
other than that
[Music]
oh it's berries in the streets
yeah hell yeah you're getting your butt
whip you can get out of there quick you
jumping in just a little Spiderman
all right let's get it community
I swear to God if you ain't following us
and you talk about this I'm gonna beat
you up
I ain't gonna bullying them into them
sit there following everybody else that
don't play with you pause
oh is this every bad for they sound yeah
oh who's the real life Lord then
[__]
oh word on the street addict said that
you know he could body you in this game
he said all those Cosmetics mean nothing
with his own
thing
oh I see you you thought you was
showing up and I didn't see you
oh
what up love
nunchucking your soul
Illuminati control my mind soul and my
body body secret society try to keep it
out
oh gosh
Come here girlfriend
hey girl
yeah they know I can get that big right
swole up on you like that
ah
pull up on you just like that ah
introduction to the blue true nation
girl
you should never be able to be this
dominant on a person
now don't let them inside that bushes
yeah boy you ain't know I was a nunchuck
number nine
I'm number one into the sun
uh yeah
armor powder
well good
I hear feet
[Music]
oh what was going down
foreign
[Music]
oh
Life's a pregnancy
hey live
the money is outside
right next to the Hut good looking out
Shadow was shortly
Brandon thank you
now if anybody could put that on Twitter
man
Boom game
it's a shadow begins
the shadow thickens
he said I see people
oh my Supremacy the body the doctor
good match
he got me back he got me back
that was hilarious I try to set him up
yo don't be robbing me for my clothes
man I like the bankies I like that suit
I had don't do that lovely weapon
this game is the best
you can try to be sneaky in it backfire
oh it's great oh my God you thought you
was gonna rise up until I turned into
the bachelor
[Music]
there you go
what up love
what up love come on man
fail me
pull up on me
I told you me and my Mansion them
crazy deadly winner
it makes no sense I could do that
evilness
dudes be winning the fight till I'm boss
up on him
shall make you regret foolishness
[Music]
way to cash it
started with a cashier
[Music]
lessons upon's lesson
I got this one dude I'm rolling with
right now his name is Felipe
oh
what's that Felipe come on Felipe let's
climb this mountain
I ain't got a team
how do you do your
power
yo I wasn't ready yet
twice
[Music]
that's the first fight I lost
wow
you're stupid
that's the first fight I love
what it says
glory is yours
how many kills I got
seven kills seven eliminations
I'm level four you say I gotta be level
five to get in that right yeah one more
one more
time
Felipe
let's go Felipe
released
yo if you look at the sky
where is he yeah I like it it's 60
frames per second
unlike restaurant only level three yeah
what you said I said it's 60 frames per
second unlike Red Bull oh man
Payback
payback
look way back
it's not smack who I wouldn't play that
who you got in there
yes
[Music]
me up
why I gotta join this course
yeah I could go work that out I'm good
that bear messed up I killed I had the
perfect clapness
the damn sneaky attic
do about thing I had this bad
I said y'all already added pick y'all
bones
I was just showing up whoever's having
beef on board
battle he cut with the highest the third
party in it yeah
I think there's only two people left
oh yeah
because I killed two people I killed
three people in all so
life Supremacy killed me both times
the last privacy face
[Music]
so it's just being all just being Eminem
I really don't like gentleman fights
he's like a vulture
Supremacy you need to thank me because
he's about
I was waiting I had everything lined up
for the boy I was like
oh I can only see his so are you five a
lot
corner
energy it's just tell me who's all alive
you're gonna say in the upper left-hand
Corner next to your off that little icon
what do we have Oh you mean
yeah
Sports
he's got plenty of grapples and
everything called yeah I messed up I
know hold on I got somebody she level
129. that's a word girlfriend
he's hunting for you
I'm talking about
what odd numbers is up that elk
so good
oh I hear you
I hate using the pistols on people
though yeah the weapons it's really not
a long distance kind of one being honest
you want to use those pistols to pick
people off when they're running from a
distance yeah
oh you better find him he's finding all
kinds of good stuff
[Music]
so if you kill him once it's a wrap
oh I got beef
in Charlotte Temple
ate me
hate me
yo you did the funniest thing is
[Music]
you're a good bad Supremacy
yo I'm climbing on the ceiling
I had nothing
bro I had no daggers I had no grappling
hooks I couldn't find nothing it's hard
on that boy when you don't have the
grapple hooks to actually loot
the good match oh I just hit him with
the double I cannot know you can hang on
the ceiling
the doctor said I was fighting for my
life again live Supremacy addict stabbed
me in the back
yeah I used my super it started yelling
hell on both of them
I killed one I think live Supremacy is
the one that survived and he ran to the
other quarter and I chased him down
that was hilarious so this was party
how did I get it
oh this is what it was but uh-huh you
didn't think I've seen you
[Music]
there you go now it's back to part okay
so before we had party of one
now dudes could party up okay so at
least had teams at three
oh
someone says I try to run up on him live
on live and quickly realize that made an
error you gotta know how to speak him no
no you better be ready
for it wait for live to be a beef with
someone else and then go on them
oh yeah for sure you could definitely be
picking up the carcasses you know what
I'm saying being a vulture out here
sure for sure
so we got
we waiting on all right so um Galveston
set the reflect only level three oh man
bro
we can do another single
yeah friend requests I see Galveston
I've seen you all right let me see
[Music]
yeah they gotta fix that though like you
can't do it quick oh we got another
person
[Music]
he shouldn't look like Dynasty Warriors
without the mobs
basically
I got the level four
all right
yeah I was waiting for the Ambush I just
didn't have no weapons
[Applause]
what happened go ahead and do teams of
two
James a two yeah team for two
party two
all right
there you go
I mean um
okay so it's just literally just running
it
yeah this is run one I got a level
okay yo all right yo coz what up I found
out something evil assistant
right no no I I know about that but you
can you go and do it up inside a room
and stay on the roof of the room if you
do the run in and they won't see you
and you can drop down on them and give
them that work
oh this this is all about me
[Music]
so right oh you ain't even tell me about
the Bell you can hit the Bell to check
it when you get an elevator right now
you know what you're shallow man he got
a belt movement are you using your
individual Powers as well before yeah
let's say somebody's running down on you
pressing Bell blocks them off
yeah it pushes them off yeah just that
get off me button yes
yes all right so um
[Music]
what is this purple barrier in the
street
look like a portal
there's an office
you're gonna stay away
let me see what this is
oh yeah it is a portal somebody my
teammate made a portal to where they
came from
that's what's up
so you can make a portal and leave that
area where you at to get to this go
ahead and uh start the two two twos okay
yeah
well I got a musket
[Music]
slow motion I don't even remember how to
play this I'm level 24 anything
to our enemies
that's right we're going to a 60-man
everyone go to the Village
Imperial yes Imperial Village
I can draw a rage
[Music]
Imperial Village guys
like for big but we gonna fight
[Music]
literally this girl named this problem
girl that's 127.
yeah
it's crazy and the dude that I got here
with me
Jimmy Jazz
[Music]
it's a shot
wow you just stole my weapon I got many
styles
it's definitely the truth
sir
I just didn't see everybody
he's got slow-mo with him so we can't
just jump him
solo 101 he don't know what he's doing
jump him
oh
yeah stupid
that's what we stick together
there's a katana right here
all right here oh
I am under siege
oh he's gotta go
yeah
oh take his clothes he got gold outfits
yes Louis Vuitton
yeah oh yeah gold dump trucks how nice
[Laughter]
these will fit well on my body
said he had gold nuns so I feel so
premium right now
what did seldo have
yeah they are done with this right now
oh yo yo your weapons feel good on me
I think they I know how to rock these
he gonna kill me
we gotta go
es
back let's go
yoga to look better on me
I get my revenge for today that'd be my
thing I don't care if I lose enough time
oh man this game is hilarious
what
the hell is that be on the lookout
stick together
I hear something oh it's just you yeah I
do
you got good hair
man you got that gold armor I mean
[Music]
who'd you take that from it's the last
I've ever seen man yo you worked real
hard for that it worked real hard for
that we just didn't took that stuff from
him
how I feel
it's on
I didn't know what I wanted to do with
it until just now
I think I'm here
oh let me try the great sword
yeah
you know what no I like those better
it's a nunchucks right here
those nunchucks is nice but they're
required
meet up with me
cool
the Anakin it is useless I have The High
Ground
but my dad
we are not coming down you're coming up
if you want the rematch so bad you're
gonna have to come up here and fight us
on our turn
hurry up
we're just gonna keep staying on High
Ground
if they want the smoke they're gonna
fight Us in some way that's not all
benefits oh I hear something the shadow
thickens
oh
[Music]
okay okay
oh
right all right all right watch out
there's people around us
oh
I'm getting bullied
that's the only way we know how to do
things
that's not chapter p
no we jump for people
we straight jump into something we have
no honor I'm okay with that and I'm okay
with it
it's all as long as we come out Victor
in the battle it's okay man so here's
the thing there's two of you you could
have easily have done that to us but we
came out first like
did you see me grapple slow mo and take
like happy
it's dirty
how many people we got left in this
world we have my weapons oh here we go
here we go
watch out don't
we were far away from the circle we had
to move oh we killed them both we
they're done we killed them twice
but there's still another
no I mean oh they are deformation in the
sand oh
and in the snow
I was saying they're done not like
everyone they're done yeah okay no more
slow-mo
backslip yourself somewhere else oh he
talking Rob Reckless
is it okay
someone who knows I'm joking I gotta
find some better armor though
no lovely weapon instead of rust you
shall be in blood
still I only got blue
oh this is where we fought last time
yeah
you talking real
[Laughter]
look man it's easy to hate slow mo you
can't get in you did it
spice
my dude just turned into a robot
oh that's that new character yeah
apparently there's like some robot
situations oh how fortunate yeah 209
yeah
yeah see the purple man
purple armor
because I don't know how good that other
dude that joined is
[Music]
guys left
yeah
can't be in the top five dead or alive
there you go
that's what I'm talking about number one
under the sun
oh they're the last dude Jack
ET
see Alma powder addict
I'm looking for something
don't want to get too far away because
yeah it don't get too full all right
there's some here
all right mark it
is
a big dude out there oh
oh I hear someone oh no I hear too
[Music]
oh we're separated we're separated
this Village is crazy detail almost like
playing multiplayer
and uh
I don't even know where you're at
I'm beefing on the ground
you got beef with the sweets
they jumped
they jumping the kids they're jumping
the kids
let's go
oh I got one
I got the doctor they was dirty
got him yeah you did it
it was a real fight though
go back
or you fill it up
I'm just saying IOP is still Victorious
and you guys aren't
like that
[Music]
oh my God you're good man
I probably got like one more hippie
though we gotta get these brothers to
level five so we can play with the pro
well I'm almost gonna be level five if I
could find the last uh
four people
are you level four down I was over four
and a half but okay I have to wait
yeah the boy you kill before y'all get
up
found them I just got a triple kill
a bowl of Barra so the match for you
[__] yo I'm gonna do one more all right
slow all right we're just waiting that
they almost finished King and lock are
almost finished
okay Supremacy you a piece man whenever
I see your character I'm like yeah we
got to jump
when I see your character I'm like
everybody there he is
a dick
boy a piece
[Music]
Madison just had breath of the wild
climbing with red cabbage with the
grapple it's interesting at least they
ain't got no stamina
I like it just how it is
I ain't got no problem with what it
doing if we can get them to the five we
can all have one match two two
yeah twos yeah
oh
how close are you one time yo
armor
who got golden armor me oh that's what's
up and I got golden nunchucks
I'm about to get real crazy we need to
get you to level five
I'm almost there we got it's it's we
just got to kill two more people how
many people left in the bench
okay so you have to very all right
yeah there they go there they go
that sounded just like us yeah
that's the word when you the worst is
when you loot it and you hear the
footsteps rolling down on you and the
music change oh no it's all you know
someone just uh someone tried to run and
I I love that feeling when you grab them
with the grappling hook and come up off
yeah
yo cut slow stupid if I kill one of
y'all imma quit mid match and go about
my day
[Laughter]
so we got one
dude let's go
it is kind of unfair that me and you
will be the ones on teams
okay you guys gotta take us out okay
okay what it says take one to Gloria
first play it just told
the trails of the game that's okay
it literally said it please let them
level you up I gotta record that cause
that was Sister Hey where's four we got
four people left alive
all right got my squad in the lobby
waiting on
D are you level five
I should be but it doesn't it doesn't
tell you until after the match yeah I'll
call them continue
oh I'm so damn close
[Music]
you want more of this y'all want more of
this
[Music]
is just about the time all right all
right let me start this one up yeah just
gotten started I'll just be the last one
okay
so we know what that for the next week
he could put nothing but purples on the
field
oh yeah my four yeah I should have how
do you cancel
you can start
no back out
can we fight in this mini game let us
bring Darkness oh yeah
all right same thing Village
Imperial you don't want to go to b-top
I mean we can that's fine let's go to
the top let's see subdue yeah
[Music]
I can only see like a little bit of it
don't let me really
golden It Go like to the top the bottom
left for the mat guys bottom left for
the mat
UK you can't like spawn in the middle of
the town but you can spawn at the very
top
[Music]
that's amazing guys
better being scared
[Music]
it says four Left Alive
oh they just kind of hide it out he's
high what dudes be doing they'll go and
they'll scale trees you should be on top
of trees and try to watch the whole back
to sleep
[Music]
that's a lot of beef though
actually if you spawn into the middle
map you'll probably get your stuff bad
fast like you'll die quick yeah
I made it to the end of the game yes
how close are you to five
and die
okay but I think they have to complete
the match to get the experience you know
when he dies the match is over for them
but okay can you level up yeah we exit
out right
yeah as long as you have to get the
level finish it you'll still get the XP
it's just you won't get as much because
you didn't beat it
but you don't need a lot so
what if my team is still playing
God want to have me be a flake yeah
you're gonna mess up your quick score
yeah I'm not trying to mess up my KD
messing with you my man Jimmy Jam's in
here with me
bro
this Sports oh that's him down there but
I'm scared I'm scared to go down there
but we're gonna have to go down there
just what it is with the situation all
right so they gave me a bowl
what happened no okay there we go I got
something this one dude
oh I hear somebody
he would ask the footage when you hear
the feet start
there's gold over here
oh did you get him is full of resources
yo people were so scared to get one in
the middle yeah they don't mess with
that
we did it I love you too
yeah I think I love YouTube first place
okay
I'ma tell you right now man just spawn
in the middle you would be so scared to
spawn in the middle
how do you do the most damage on your
team and then
I'll get the most careful oh it's a
Chesapeake yeah I don't know
I don't have one match I was killing mad
people and I'm winning chicken dinner
got the most
I gotta play some Pub G thank you for
telling me that
oh [__] I hear something
oh that's that little chest that just be
making noise
all right guys that was fun I'm gonna uh
all right brother five I'm like a little
bit away yeah left our next stream we
are bringing this back we doing this
yeah for sure let's do it all right put
y'all in the middle yeah or whatever
yeah have a go a lot all right
yeah
and you be offline man so nobody knows
I'm offline all the time
I'm offline all the time but I'm here
though
yeah
all right all right catch you in a
minute brother I'm upset all right we're
still not beef
oh it was lucky trunk because I was like
somebody named Lucky Charms came in
Mr Holmes
oh I never I haven't got a chance to
play with them boys all right I see
something that may be of use
you see another blue let me know
this is girlfriend
so
look at a creek it's hot as hell
you have fun I'm playing this
a double jump into a grappling hook into
a room
the mantle over they get they got their
man to perfect yes it's best lit the way
you could just scale so easy
and people lose this
see nobody oh this this is wooden lift
you up
I need Grappler hooks
yeah I'm starting to run out too
the enemy spotted on the map
come on oh I see you
he was following me
oh can I get those
all right
the shadow begins
everybody just looting cause I don't see
them
oh lots of privacy
a lot of Supremacy building with last
privacy too
oh I hit I hit I hit it
oh you scared me I was like oh it's dead
you
didn't know who I was
got it [__] up challenge
that's my short right there
I'm ready
man it's ready
kill a monk from the funk
first win let me kill you that's your
teammate are you five though that's the
question
oh go
I am God Sterling equipment devoid of
course
a pleasant fluke
oh yes
I got something that may be of you I got
a gold armor
oh you gotta goal that's what's up
[Music]
they are here all right let's wrap it
let's move
dumbass you thought I was whack
I'm that guy
nah man I'm gonna tell you right now
doesn't get you hella talking boy
yes but that work in
any work yet yeah he worked it
hang on in there oh you have stuff there
man um
Sterling equipment the void of curses
a pleasant floor yeah your clothes look
nice on the god
good luck at all was that Balenciaga let
me throw your balloon
oh
yeah you robbing people
really wearing red bottoms now
dirty I like to know where they went I
know where they at it I send them to the
airport I think they're waiting to jump
us like they're probably looking at us
looking for us
yo I did that special move I said God
oh you did the move yeah I hung upside
down she tried to uh drench me in some
water
I was like oh what you doing with that
water stuff I wiped that off I said
little man
oh it's a big day
attached
huh
oh
scared the hell up
[Music]
you know how to counter though right
yeah
yeah so that is only the count of the
big where they glow up
laughs
I thought y'all's gonna jump me
you thought she was nice sorry little
man
there you go
come here
and I take your Soul Essence
so Essence is mine
foreign
[Music]
thank you
oh he switched up
[Music]
we out
he became
that is that who we used to fight before
the attic Runs The High Ground
he snitched up on his performance
using the guy I use yeah yeah yeah
we killed one of them though
I'm in the temple of the Gods
here go and heal your sword even though
dude
he outside with it the outside they
probably regrouped by now
we gotta go for the dude that didn't
turn into a demon
oh that's me
are you there he is
yeah
all right we're sticking up on them
we're sneaking up on him
Big Bear course to the east
shall route
oh they they're where we were
you
oh you want to do
I feel like they're trying to they're
trying to play us they're trying to the
shadow will shortly begin
foreign
[Music]
way too much fun
he said he's leaving the community oh
there's two of them
the Dust he's here
oh they run watch out
they jump with the kids the kid's in
trouble
they're jumping again
if I die we've all died together
we all die in bird together
yes you it's an excuse logos
with me we will burn
[Music]
I'm at the highest point in this game
oh my God
I'm about to die he said Lord addict is
ready to go there
no no no
he bodied you no I'm so good
oh you're still alive you're just
running from the smoke
what's up to you it's y'all too got a
title too no you coming back I can't you
should be able to
it says nothing no revive left
now it may perform
to the Head
[Music]
nobody made a tactical error
he tried to heal yeah
he won't play games
[Music]
that was hilarious I love last Christmas
I was gonna take him in a place where we
could fight his equals he tried to do
that dirty stuff alone right you want to
play dirty we'll play dirty you're like
damn dad
yo I'ma need all of you right now to
tweet on Twitter the attitude
won every game we played
you're talking about spicy
especially you like Supremacy you try to
fight me in the storm and got stung bro
I respect it though he's like we're
gonna die out of this battlefield and
burn together
hmm
good badshah good [__]
[Laughter]
and Bloodbath
yep
[Music]
gotta get at it I mean what you call it
okay
you have to leave no we have to do we
have to play together
yeah
Lobby
no no oh you're just doing it right yeah
but there will be one person sure and
slow Mosley
because we only had like if lock and him
could have did we could have did two two
twos but like we just did so we just do
it we're doing everything so let's know
us three uh like threes let's go into
the actual playlist
all without the communities yeah yeah
because we we got to do one of us three
like we got to all right all right I
appreciate it
the doctor's privacy laborers the little
brother that was a lot of fun are you
presenting me something
oh he said hi to me
yeah
I'm closing I'm closing it expand the
road
oh man I accepted y'all yeah
[Music]
soon
make sure y'all add me in game
brush
[Music]
there's also a campaign one day we gotta
try that I'm looking mad
yo stop
my control my headset's dead so I can't
use both of these
to that give me one second
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
I'm good now just ready up
oh we're gonna hop this up though
our oil ready up
King you got it ready up okay now you
did
y'all couldn't hear me
I'm sitting there like yeah y'all can
hear me yeah so yeah it was really fun
it was done for a doctor I appreciate
y'all but salute
I get a chance to Get Swole on your
balls you may have my power
I'm going in the middle I'm going to
Celeste celestra
that's what I'm about I'm about the
Middle Lane
yo that one map I was on it had some
High Point
I was at the top top of this Cavern I
was fighting all these dudes inside the
whatchamacallit
I'm on a community stream this is it
right here
this is naraka uh blade point
liquid Chris ax
[Music]
eight seconds huh
I don't I said I'm gonna cook the food
I'm just letting you know
all right love you
or do you think
Fist of the lotus
all right
now I was acting up I know I sat there I
learned he was my favorite at first too
I used to love oh he's so so good
yeah but you took clouds come down
he fit my style a little bit when it
come to they try to jump you you got
some good moves to anti jump
I got a weapon man
yeah me too I got nunchucks
in a gun
all right let me go over there I'll let
you know people
I'm about to build it underneath
oh
we gotta pull
I'm gonna start saying when you guys say
pause I'm saying go
you can go for it
yeah there's two of them
King they're over where you are
press right here to log into Focus aim
on an enemy
hello
I'm over here I'm gonna hurt them
this is just no time for peace
come on with all your uh jumping in
after dude getting his killer bro attic
is who that that's that's attic man
get out of here we don't need you to
make sure
well he is fighting someone I'm fighting
about my durability is quack
let me get over there so I can check the
map
yeah slow
gotta repair your chairman
yep
I see you
oh there's a gold bull yard let's go
over here
my weapon is restored
are you sure
[Music]
the ass still Awakening is here
you'll be able to do it
wow crazy
you need better armor yeah yeah I know I
gotta get out more
but I got a chance for you
I got some stuff down here
right here for you okay hold on hold on
got people on me bro oh all right
y'all seen them over there on the south
side thanks
[Music]
I was
doing that and then dude came over I
thought it was y'all
I got home
there's more people over there
I saw them fighting on the other side
I just got more of them I'm good yeah I
just see you tonight yeah yeah when I
beat their bodies I stealing stuff
all right let's go this way
you gotta Market on the map Market on a
map sort of press select to bring up the
map
same thing like fortnite
oh where you want us to go
yeah
make for this one away
yo you should grab a little hook on them
yeah
it's here
till we beat the brakes off that boy I
hear I hit it I hear grapple this boy
out four outside yo
man be right inside the inside yeah it
is uh
thank you
it's lovely freshly hammered a lot oh
oh
I'll get jumped off
thank you
God
so they try to run oh they shot him
right after
Anthony
got him that's why I like the little
I got him
cool the dude that was trying to rush
that's why I like going into the middle
one
the Mad action
oh you need purple
all right as soon as I find some purple
I got you
foreign
Nobody Got No Berries
defense Barry regular berries
gotta check this
note the item I have marked oh there you
go yeah
who's texting me like they crazy bro
no it's oh that's that
all the people there's people
there we go Converge on my marker yeah
he has multiple people
okay
[Music]
that one of these got out of purpose
yeah I just grabbed him
I just take the essence
it is time it has to be helping repair
stuff
has it freshly hammered and brought I
left the bunch over there
no Soldier L2 because they got a little
synergies or certain weapons
good look yeah I mean
their own King
oh God
[Music]
you gotta run
already got kicked
by The Souls of their films
got one all right let me get King out
there
oh my good stuff
you don't die okay
thank you
oh someone's stalling stuff yeah
somebody's shooting us from the back oh
yeah Jesus
Gladius
shooting
down
get him get him kick oh oh up here up
here I have marks
oh he counted me yeah buddy yeah I
counted
yeah kill help get your Shields up
all right go
again
how do you make a disarm you yep
King uh pop some armor stuff if you have
it I don't have any
yeah spam out and look for some of your
Technique
we can't have you have that
logo
now it may perform its function again
all right take this
thank you
as strong as my heart
[Laughter]
yo we gotta get over here
I marked it
people up on the mountain
they fight
third partying
oh yeah yeah oh there's a bunch of them
oh it's wild
yeah
oh man
stop your [__] right there boys
you gotta jump Jamiroquai
what is he doing
oh my God
I'm good I dropped that um
oh two people three yeah
oh that's your kid yes sir
with yourself
always
this one
King leave us
can't get off the smoke away Bobby
healing me
I'm right here all right get him
well I would have died
I'm about to die
where are you I'm right here just run
you gotta go thank you
yeah somebody's at the house I know I'm
on the outside of the house yeah okay
I got you
Cog you down I got you
you are so deep in school
it ain't long
Hill the moment you get up
I've tried
oh
yeah but fortnite see the thing of
fortnite if we're in the the the storm
yeah we ain't got to panic that's why I
wasn't panicking no oh so this is the
Jeff oh
okay no no that's what's up
I didn't know that that's the only thing
I would I would I would have left but
it doesn't matter it was dope yeah it
didn't matter so I'm just I gotta learn
different things with this that's what's
up
hell yeah it's fine all right do your
thing I gotta I gotta go cook the food
take a picture of that plus on Twitter
[Music]
but this which one oh damn I already
left main menu yeah I took a picture too
okay all right catch y'all later all
right catch y'all later good stream
y'all appreciate y'all ILP 300 if you
ain't there you ain't nowhere tomorrow
God bless you had it bye guys I'm tired
that was a long stream
I'm streamed every day this week is the
stream still running